[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue C sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur Public Sénat 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité et aux
crises que nous traversons et justement
vous êtes nombreux à vouloir comprendre
le dessous des cartes au proch Orient
après les attaques terroristes du Hamas
et la Rost en cours de l'armée
israélienne c'est donc une émission
spéciale que je vous propose
ce soir avec cette opération militaire
inédite qui se met en place autour de la
bande de Gaza défi pour l'armée
israélienne comment répliquer aux
terroristes du Hamas sans mettre en
danger la vie de leurs centaines
d'otages l'État hébreux entre en guerre
rappelle ses réservistes mais quelle
forme prendra la ripost quelle est la
stratégie du Hamas pour combien de temps
encore la parole des modérés des faisur
de paix restera inaudible dans cette
partie du monde ce sera notre premier
débat et puis juste après c'est le
pouvoir du Premier ministre israélien
que l'on
questionnera cette guerre nous a été
imposée par un ennemi abominable des
bêtes humaines qui célèbrent le meurtre
des femmes d'enfants et de personnes
âgées benamin netiou qui promet un GLF
de fer aux ennemis d'Israël peut-il
réunir le pays autour de lui former un
gouvernement d'union nationale alors
qu'il est critiqué notamment pour son
aveuglement face au ramas comment ses
alliés internationaux États-Unis en tête
vont peser sur son avenir on répondra à
ces questions dans 3ois quart d'heure
mais d'abord la situation autour de la
bande de Gaza et à l'intérieur
2300000 habitants désormais coupés du
monde Jérôme
Rabier c'est un bilan terrible et qui ne
cesse de s'alourdir les autorités
israéliennes dénombrent désormais plus
de 1000 morts et 2400 blessés dans
l'offensive du Hamas sur son territoire
250 cors de civil israéliens ont été
comptabilisés sur le seul site du
festival de musique qui se tenait à
quelques kilomètres à l'est de Gaza et
plus d'une centaine dans le kibut béi
durement frappé par les assaillants 4
jours après ces attaques il y aurait
aussi plus d'une centaine d'otages
emmenés de force dans la bande de Gaza
fi du mouvement islamiste prenant hier
soir la parole pour la première fois le
Premier ministre israélien a promis une
réponse implacable
mais je vous assure chers concitoyens
qu'à la fin de la campagne tous nos
ennemis sauront que c'était une terrible
erreur d'attaquer
Israël ce qui sera fait à nos ennemis
dans les jours à venir risonnera en eux
pendant des générations les dor un
discours soutenu par les chancelleries
occidentales qui appui Israël dans son
droit à se défendre au côté d'Olaf schz
Emmanuel Macron a dénoncé les
terroristes palestiniens qui promett bre
des otages en cas d'attaque sur Gaza
évidemment le chantage qui est fait par
le Hamas c'est un insupportable
chantage que nous ne pouvons que
condamner que nous condamnons avec
fermeté en représaille Israël impose un
blocus total à la bande de Gaza où
vivent 2 millions et demi de Gazaoui
depuis 4 jours les frappes de l'armée
israélienne s'enchaînent sur ce
territoire détruisant officiellement les
lieux stratégiques pour le Hamas mais ce
blocus total est dénoncé par une partie
de la communauté internationale ONU en
tête l'imposition de sièges qui metent
en danger la vie des civils en les
privant de biens essentiel à leur survie
est interdite par le droit international
humanitaire Israël qui a rappelé 300000
réservistes continue d'amasser ses
troupes à proximité de ses frontières
dont une bonne partie près de Gaza
laissant présager une offensive
terrestre imminente dans cette enclave
palestinienne surpeuplée dirigé par le
Hamas depuis
2007 je vous présente tout de suite mes
invités Dominique trincand bonsoir
bienvenue ancien chef de la mission
militaire française à l'ONU auteur de ce
livre ce qui nous attend l'effet
papillon des conflits mondiaux aux
éditions Robert Lafond Patricia
Lemmonier bonsoir vous êtes grand
reporteur spécialist des relations
internationales ce livre auteur au cœur
du chaos vous publiez aux éditions harto
vous avez été correspondante pour TF1 en
Israël vous avez couvert notamment
plusieurs opérations de l'armée
israélienne à Gaza et la première
Jean-Paul chagnolo bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes professeur émérite de
sciences politiques à l'Université de
Sergy Pontoise et président de
l'Institut de recherche et d'études
Méditerranées Moyen-Orient auteur de ce
livre Israël-Palestine la défaite du
vainqueur qui est publié aux édition
Acte Sud on est également en duplexe
avec Julien baloule qui est spécialiste
de la société israélienne ancien
journaliste et également ancien
porte-parole réserviste de tsal bonsoir
à vous et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation et Laétitia crupa
éitorialiste politique bonsoir Laetitia
bien bienvenue à vous Dominique trincon
je commence avec vous peut-être pour
caractériser la la ripost de de l'armée
israélienne en tout cas ce que l'on en
sait en cette fin d'après-midi de mardi
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une première
phase sous entendu il y en aura beaucoup
d'autres oui alors tout à fait une
d'abord il faut retenir les paroles du
Premier ministre israélien euh qui a
parlé de détruire le Hamas je ne l'ai
pas entendu parler des otages c'est un
indicateur h le 2èe point c'est que la
première phase effectivement l'armée
israélienne est en train de se mobiliser
donc pour l'instant il y a des frappes
essentiellement des frappes aériennes
mais pas que euh c'est ce qu'on appelle
les frappes qui modèlent le champ de
bataille pendant que l'armée euh bloque
euh Gaza et que la mobilisation continue
et la phase suivante ça sera
probablement le moment où euh il sera
décidé d'envoyer l'armée dans Gaza h euh
avec toutes les difficultés que ça
représente difficulté d'abord parce que
aller chercher les otages va être
quasiment mission impossible il y a pas
de renseignement ils sont sûrement
dispersés dans l'ensemble de la de la
ville deuxièmement après les frappes là
c'est le terrien qui passe les les
frappes aériennes ont un inconvénient
dans une ville c'est que ça fait
beaucoup d'obstacles et les obstacles ça
aide les défenseurs et je pense que le
Hamas s'est préparé à se défendre donc
ça risque d'être extrêmement difficile
je rappelle simplement que la dernière
opération d'envergure dans une ville
c'était Mossou ça a pris plusieurs mois
h euh donc voilà on est dans ces phases
successives mais moi je retiens
l'objectif stratégique qui est la
destruction de Hamas du Hamas Patricia
lemmonère évidemment parce que si on
cherche à comparer ce qui ce qui
pourrait se passer dans les prochains
jours aux précédentes opérations
militaire de l'armée israélienne à
l'intérieur de la de la bande de Gaza il
y a une une inconnue c'est celle dont
vous devez parler c'est le sort de ces
100 150 otages ça ça change tout d'une
certaine façon oui ça ça change mais pas
pas pas pas tant que ça parce que tout
va dépendre des choix qui vont être
faits par les militaires si les
militaires décident on y va coûte que
coûte et ce qui est important c'est le
premier objectif qui est d'éradiquer le
Hamas et ses chefs les otages passent
après et ce qui est intéressant c'est
d'écouter certains témoignages en Israël
où des gens disent euh nos otages sont
déjà morts pour certains quand vous
écoutez ça vous avez effectivement froid
au dos mais ils le disent c'est-à-dire
queil y a une telle euh un tel sursaut
euh en Israël qu'ils sont prêts pour
certains à pass ils veulent les sauver
mais si le prix à payé pour éradiquer
pensent-t-il totalement le Hamas ce que
je pense n'est pas possible parce que
dans les dernières opérations on l' il
avait tenté d'être fait ça et ils
étaient ils avaient ils étaient revenus
en pleine forme on peut le voir avec des
des des armes encore plus sophistiquées
et bien si c'est d'éradiquer et
d'essayer de détruire tout ce qui
représente Hamas et leur chef et bien
les otages passeront après ouais
évidemment évidemment ils ils essayeront
de les chercher et puis dernier point
les otages sont dispersés ça c'est
certain euh les Hamas c'est pas
totalement idiot ils dispersent ses
otages et sûrement très bien caché voilà
quand à la menace terrain on parle de
cour terrain pas il faut si vous voulez
on peut pas dire mais enfin en tout cas
ils sont en tout cas cachés au mieux et
estce que et quand à la menace de dire
dès que vous taper un immeuble on en
assassine un c'est quand vous tapez un
immeuble sans nous prévenir oui sans
soltion voà parce qu'effectivement il y
a des sommations moi que j'ai été
effectivement et et les gens sont
prévenus soit quand le téléphone
portable marche par portable parce que
tout le monde ils ont les tous les
portables ou par d'autres moyens de
communication les gens sont prévenus
mais parfois le temps est tellement
court que les gens on pas le temps de
sortir juste juste une remarque euh ce
ne sont pas les militaires qui prendront
la décision c'est une décision politique
évidment le militaire va dire si vous
voulez voilà voilà le risque et cetera
et finalement c'est le politique qui
prendra la dcision vous je vais dire que
les militaires obéissent au politique
hein on on y reviendra à cette dimension
liée lié aux otages et notamment aux
otages français parce qu'il y a des il y
a des il y a des otages français
Jean-Paul sagnolo quand vous entendez le
Premier ministre israélien dire
éradiquer le Hamas qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire bah ça veut dire qu'il n rien
compris au problème en fait tout
simplement c'est dire que nous avons une
organisation qui a commis des crimes de
guerre h euh là-dessus il faut être
clair mais c'est une organisation cri
contre l'humanité CRIM contre l'humanité
des crimes de guerre ils ont été tués
non non ils ont été tués parce qu'ils
étaient juifs ce sont des crimes contre
l'humité CRIM deery cri de guerre voir
des crimes contre l'humanité mais le
problème c'est que cette organisation
c'est pas un groupe terroriste comme ça
qui est qui est sans sans enracinement
il représente aux dernières élections
qui sont anciennes environ 30 ou 35 % de
la population palestinienne et aux
dernières élections de 2021 qui n'ont
pas eu lieu à mon avis il aurait d'après
les sondage car il y a des sondages en
Palestine il aurait sans doute eu la
majorité et aujourd'hui on pourra en
discuter si vous
voulez donc la notion d'éradiquer le de
Hamas c'est une absurdité évidemment on
choisit pas son ennemi celui-là est
terrible mais on choisit pas son ennemi
éadiquer les têtes on peut évidemment on
peut on peut on peut toucher on peut
toucher l'appareil mais c'est en plus
c'est une vieille histoire ça ça remonte
à très longtemps ça remonte à aux années
96 et juste un point d'histoire quand
même en en 95 96 c'estàd en plein
processus d' slow où on avait encore
l'espérance quelque part qu'il pouvait y
avoir une négociation elle avait lieu
mais malheureusement elle a pas abouti
cétait un naufrage il y avait deux
acteurs qui n'en voulaient pas de ces de
ces de ce processus le Hamas qui a
commis des attentats moand j'étais en
Israël à cette époque là j'ai j'ai vu
concrètement ces C ces attentats
terroristes notamment au cœur de
Jérusalem en face de la grande poste
j'ai des souvenir très concrets de ça et
puis il y avait la la droite l'extrême
droite et la droite israélienne qui n'en
voulait pas et le le patron de cette
droite c'était netaniaou qui é élu
premier ministre en
1996 et les gens qui ont tué Rabine en
novembre le 4 novembre 1995 sont des
gens qui appartiennent à une mouvance
politique de l'extrême droite et ces
gens-là sont aujourd'hui au pouvoir
parti des alli F partie des gens comme
Benv ou smrich sont des alliés donc on a
cette configuration on a deux blocs
finalement les pires deux extrmist il se
retrouve aujourd'hui à nouveau 30 ans
plus tard et au fond ils sont
coresponsables de de du drame que nous
vivons aujourd'hui je dis ça parce que
quand on entend qui dit la guerre a
commencé non c'est pas vrai la guerre
elle est c'est c'est une situation dont
il faut rappeler tout de même en terme
juridique et politique c'est uneation
d'occupation il y a une occupation
militaire depuis 67 l'armée israélienne
est une armée d'occupation de la
sisjordanie et l'enfermement de Gaza
donc il faut remettre quand même ça en
perspective et à partir de là nous
sommes dans le drame dont sont
responsables je dirais coresponsa les
radicaux du Hamas et et la droite qui
n'a jamais
voulu de netanah qui disait oslo est un
est le problème pas la solution voilà
ouis effectivement mais ça il faut que
ces parolesl puissent être entendu mais
c'est difficile
dans l'émotion du moment voyez ce que
jeux dire oui bien sûr on est d'accord
Julien Balou vouliz intervenir peut-être
sur la je reviens au otages la dimension
symbolique des otages pour la société
israélienne oui je voudrais dire deux
choses en fait la première c'est que on
sait que dans la dans la société
israélienne la question des otages
question très sensible on a vu par
exemple que en 2011 Israël a libérer
plus de 1000 terroristes palestiniens
pour libérer un soldat le soldat donc là
a des dizaines dis d'tage vous imaginez
le le prix que que Israël sera prêt à à
payer pour les libérer et donc on sait
que les organisations islamistes
palestiniennes s'en servent comme carte
parce que comme carte pardon parce
qu'elles savent que Israël sera prêt à
payer le prix donc en knappant des des
otages ils pourront obtenir plus de de
de choses donc le fait qu'Israël ne
définisse pas dès le début de
l'opération que les otages soient un
objectif c'est aussi pour faire baisser
le prix des négociation et ne pas le
faire enflammer et d'ailleurs ils ont
ils ont déclaré en off/ash on parce que
le but était évidemment ce soit dans
toute la presse ils ont dit la question
des prisonniers des otages pardon parce
que c'est pas des prisonniers les
prisonniers ont des droits les otages ne
sera aborder que après la guerre jeis
dire un un un une autre chose sur le le
fait de l'enfernement de Gaza et et
l'occupation en si Jordan occupation qui
qui est réelle en tout cas d'une partie
de la population palestinienne qui vit
réellement sous occupation militaire en
revanche la bande de Gaza donc est
indépendante depuis 2005 il y a pas un
israélien qui habite là-bas depuis 2005
et je voudrais juste faire remarquer que
depuis 2005 il y a eu plusieurs cycles
de conflits entre Israël et le Hamas
plusieurs guerres avec à chaque fois des
frappes israéliennes extrêmement fortes
a extrêmement important et extrêmement
beaucoup de dégâts et depuis une aide
internationale qui est arrivée par
milliards de dollars qui était censé
restaurer la bande de Gaza développer la
bande de Gaza or on voit que la bande de
Gaza ne s'est pas développé par contre
qu'est-ce qui s'est développé c'est
l'arsenal de guerre de la de la du bande
du Hamas les missiles de Hamas qui sont
de plus en plus forts plus importants et
plus puissants donc on voit clairement
où va l'argent donc oui il y a une
question c'est vrai de politique isralne
sur la fermeture de la frontière mais en
réalité on voit que la frontière était
pas vraiment fermée puu qu'ils sont
passé aisément d'autre part il y a un
point de passage avec l'Égypte où la
l'Égypte aussi a une énorme
responsabilité parce qu'elle pourrait
largement laisser passer tout ce qu'elle
veut par sa frontière et enfin si
l'arsenal de guerre du Hamas se
développe autant enfin regardez ce
qu'ils ont réussi à tirer depuis le
début de la guerre c'est que clairement
il y a de l'argent qui circule
simplement il va à d'autres fins que
développement de la populationou et puis
aussi et je vous redonnerai la parole
plus tard évidemment Julien Balou mais
on en a longuement parlé hier une
question de on va dire d'aveuglement
stratégique de Benjamin netanahou qui a
laissé le le Hamas se développer
finalement et se et s'armer dans la
bande de Gaza en se tournant plutôt vers
les les colons et la S Jordanie on parle
je je reviens sur la la qualification
des des faits euh parce que cette
question elle va forcément se poser
crime de guerre crime contre l'humanité
pourquoi vous dites crime contre
l'humanité parce que les les cibles
étaient juives et il fallait tuer les
Juifs ça s'appelle un crime contre
l'humanité un crime de guerre c'est
autre chose c'est vous tirez sur un
objectif
et dans l'action de guerre et vous tuez
des civils et des civils indistinctement
parce qu'ils habitaient là donc là c'est
un crime de guerre si parce que vous
n'avez pas le droit de tirer sur des
civils en revanche quand vous ciblez
spécifiquement des personnes et là c'est
le cas vous massacrez des Juifs vous
êtes dans la qualification de crime
contre l'UM é et c'est important de le
souligner parce qu'il faut quand même
rappeler que l'État d'Israël existe
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale pour protéger les Juifs après
la choix c'était ça le but et et là en
fait il se trouve sur le
territoire israélien normalement protégé
par l'armée c'est là où je dis c'est la
une faute complète de la stratégie de de
Monsieur netaniaou c'est qu'il aurait dû
protéger le territoire et en fait il ne
l'a pas protégé parce qu'il s'est
intéressé à laass Jordanie et donc il a
manqué à la mission première qui est de
protéger les Juifs sur le territoire
israélien allez patricimère un mot
là-dessus et ensuite je vous redonne la
parole je je pense aussi que cette ce
qui est en train de se dérouler
aujourd'hui et cette violence qui s'est
exercé en en Israël ce massacre et et ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en en Gaza
montre aussi alors notre responsabilité
à nous communauté internationale et ça
on pourrait revenir mais aussi montre
l'échec du militaire parce que il y a eu
effectivement quatre opérations massives
quand même importantes d'ailleurs dans
laquelle en 2014 74 soldats israéliens
sont morts et 2000 Palestiniens à peu
près enfin voyez euh
donc c'est le choc qui est donc ces
opérations militaires n'ont pas
fonctionné elles n'ont pas réussi à
éradiquer voire même on a vu avec la
dernière en 2021 on a découvert des
missiles beaucoup plus puissants
effectivement qu'avant donc ça ça ça
montre que le tout sécuritaire et quand
quand on va dans le le mur en essayant
de pas trouver de solution effectivement
on aboutit à ça et aujourd'hui on se
trouve devant un traumatisme comme le 11
septembre vous imaginez le 11 septembre
quand vous parlez encore aux Américains
aujourd'hui du 11 septembre il tremblent
encore donc ce qui veut dire que dans 20
ans les Israéliens trembleront encore en
en pensant à cette histoire et qu'est-ce
qu'on fait les États-Unis ils n'ont fait
que du militaire ils ont cherché à punir
à écraser et à raser et ça n'a pas
marché on le voit aujourd'hui
Afghanistan Irak et cetera donc la si la
solution du tout militaire ne marchera
pas oui et et ce sont des ferments de de
guerre future de vengeance future sauf
qu'aujourd'hui en Israël Jean-Paul
chagnolo je je je sais pas qui peut
tenir ce discours et s'il est audible
par la société israélienne ça le le
militaire n'est pas la solution oui mais
si vous voulez le problème c'est qu'on
on prend cette histoire comme si elle
avait commencé
samedi c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
ramener un peu à une perspective c'est
ce qu'on dit quand on dit que la
violence et c'est vrai que que le
militaire ne mène à rien ne mène à rien
vous savez il y a une fameuse formule de
Raymont Haron qui disait le militaire
sans diplomate il n'existe pas le
diplomate sans le militaire n'existe pas
c'est c'est incontestable bon gagner bon
pas faire la pub pour un bouquin mais la
défaite du vainqueur ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que on a gagné sur le plan
militaire très bien so what et après et
s'il y a pas une dimension politique on
abouti à rien et malheureusement quand
j'évoqué tout à l'heure les deux acteurs
d'il y a 30 ans ils se sont engagés dans
des tunnels militaires où finalement R
que dans tout sécuritaire et là
aujourd'hui on ne parle qu'en terme de
sécurité ce qui est absurde et la
communauté internationale est
extrêmement responsable il y a il y a
quand même le dernier geste politique de
la communauté internationale c'est une
résolution qui date maintenant de 7 ans
c'était en décembre 2016 la résolution
2334 du 23 décembre 2016 qui disait il
faut arrêter la colonisation il faut
arrêter Israël en tant que puissance
occupante et ce bon il y a eu aucun
concret pourquoi parce que nous sommes
en décembre 2016 excusez-moi de faire un
peu d'histoire qui Arve qui arrive 20
jours plus tard
après c'est un Donald Trump et Donald
Trump a complètement rversé les choses
la communauté internationale ne peut pas
de façon exogène comme ça imposer
à 40s qu'on est dans un il y a eu il y a
eu des moments par exemple dans les
années 2012 2013 a essayé mais on a
abandonné toute tentative depuis
maintenant disons une dizaine d'années
et alors évidemment dans ces cas-là on
est dans le sécuritaire et ce qui s'est
passé là ce qui se passe aujourd'hui n'a
pas d'issu car on va aller on va aller
qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir une offensive
alors on va discuter de l'offensive
terrestre se dérouler et Cera bon so il
va y avoir une tragédie à tous égards et
après on va se retrouver avec des
cendres et audelà des cendres on fait
quoi on était trop content de mettre le
problème sous le tapis bien sûr et si et
si on ne ressort pas du politique
collectivement la question palestinienne
n'était plus au centre des on va dire
des discussions et des relations
internationales Julien Balou je repose
la la question finalement le le benjamin
Nanah a-t-il d'autres choix qu'une
riposte militaire même si on a bien
compris vu son positionnement politique
c'est de l'option qu'il qu'il qu'il
pourrait mettre prioritairement en avant
mais vu la réaction de la société
israélienne aujourd'hui a-t-il d'autres
choix alors plusieurs choses moi je je
suis très à l'aise pour parler Deo parce
que j'assche clairement mon mes
positions politiques sur Twitter toute
l'année j'ai manifesté toute l'année
contre sa politique et contre ce
gouvernement donc on ne peut pas me
soupçonner de venir faire la la
propagande du gouvernement israélien je
l'ai affiché depuis depuis très
longtemps et encore une fois j'ai fait
tous les mouvements de protestations et
les manif et des grèves contre la
réforme de la justice la question n'est
pas là aujourd'hui une question qui a
euh une question d'unité nationale je
peux dire aujourd'hui que toutes les
querelles d'hier n'ont pas cours
aujourd'hui en Israël tous ceux qui
étaient qui se disputai sur des
questions de de question intérieur
aujourd'hui se prennent dans les bras
mes amis qui avaient dit qu' allit plus
faire le service leur service de réserve
ils ont été les premiers à courir à
mettre leur uniforme à tout retourner
dans dans l'armée pourquoi parce que
tout le monde voit bien que le pays est
en danger que le pays est attaqué et
tout le monde tout le monde tout le
monde tout le monde veut aider j'ai des
amis encore une fois des gens les plus à
gauche au G plus à droite tout le monde
est uni tout le monde veut aller aider
tout le monde veut aller sauver les les
les otages tout le monde veut aller la
aider la population qui est sous les
missilees dans le sud du pays j'ai des
amis qui sont allés acheter des des des
matelas pour aller donner à des soldats
qui sont mobilisés j'ai des amis qui
sont allés donner leur sang j'ai des
amis qui sont all le supermarché
collecta la nourriture pour les autres
donc tout le monde mobilisé donc ça n'a
pas je pense de lien avec les positions
politiques de netanahou parce que on
parle de plus de 900 morts 900 morts sur
la plupart des civils 260 personnes qui
ont été tué dans un festival de musique
dans le Bataclan il y en avait 90 juste
pour vous donner une idée de de de
de des dimensions on un pay de 9
millions d'habitants je sais pas si vous
voyez ce que ça fait au niveau de l'ch
de la France ça serait des milliers de
victimes qui aurent été tué en France
par des centaines de saleslam ou de
Mohamed mer donc c'est très important de
de comprendre ça ensuite un autre point
sur l'horizon politique on parle
beaucoup des positions politiques des
Israéliens et du du gouvernement
israélien c'est important un mot de la
la scène politique palestinienne
peut-être les Palestiniens en 2005 2006
pardon mettent au pouvoir les islamistes
du Hamas en 2007 le Hamas prend le
pouvoir de force de la bande de Gaza et
exécute ses opposants et depuis empêche
toute tenue d'élection dans la bande de
Gaza le président palestinien Mar mabas
c'est au pouvoir depuis janvier 2005
pour un mandat de 5 ans et il est au
pouvoir depuis 2005 sans partage et sans
élection faut auss de rappeler il y a
aucun horison politique sur la scène
palestinienne il y a personne à qui
donner les clés côté palestinien oui la
solution militaire uniquement militaire
on est d'accord aucun avenir mais là
actuellement aujourd'hui il y a pas
d'autre choix je je vous interrom on
reviendra vers vous pardon pour les
petites coupures de de liaison avec avec
Julien Balou à T vous on parlait des
réservistes 300000 réservistes mobilisés
par l'armée israélienne parmi eux des
franco-israéliens comme yoval il devait
commencer des études de de math et de
sciences ce dimanche il rejoint son
unité de réserve il témoignit sur France
interre en préservant son anonymat on
l'écoute comme l'armée en Israël est
obligatoire euh pour la jeunesse
israélienne à l'âge de 18 ans comm son
service militaire euh le va va le faire
pour 2 ans 3 ans euh même plus des fois
et pour toute notre vie en fait partie
toujours de l'armée on peut être appelé
comme on n'a pas assez de de population
pour avoir une armée professionnelle à
la fin on est les la les circonstances
nous poussent à avoir un service
militaire obligatoire des gens qui sont
pas forcément de nature militaire la
plupart euh vont devoir être
combattant Dominique Trincant c'estes
réservistes est-ce qu'ils peuvent se
retrouver du jour au lendemain au combat
au contact direct de l'ennemi oui bien
sûr mais quand on est en Israël on on
connaît le sujet je veux dire c'est
courant moi quand je je commandais mon
bataillant au Liban j'allais souvent
d'abord à l'époque une partie du Liban
était occupée par Israël donc on voyait
l'armée l'armée israélienne évidemment
il y avait des rotations il tournaient
il faisaient des des des des des
sessions et cetera euh ce qui vient
d'être dit je reviens juste sur le 11
septembre puisque j'ai vécu cette époque
aux États-Unis je crois que c'est
exactement la même euh le 11 septembre
ça a débouché sur quoi sur l'Afghanistan
on sait comment ça s'est terminé sur
l'Irak on voit le c que ça a mis dans la
zone du Moyen-Orient c'est-à-dire que
les aux États-Unis à l'époque il y avait
unité national aussi vous ne pouviez pas
parler d'autres choses les Français qui
étaient au Conseil de sécurité contre
contre les Américains se faisaient
injurier dans la rue hein donc ça ça
n'était pas possible de faire autre
chose donc aujourd'hui on voit bien on
est un peu tous dans cette situation là
on dit mais finalement il y a pas
d'autre solution à cause du drame que ça
représente maintenan euh il faut
regarder vers l'avant et voir sur quoi
va déboucher ce drame et ça on disait à
mes camarades américains militaires je
leur disais 2003 la guerre en Irak dis
pas de problème vous gagnerez la guerre
rouleau compresseur mais la paix
qu'est-ce que vous ferez et eux même les
militaires américain disaent vous avez
raison on y arrivera pas alors on
parlait de ce ce climat d'union
nationale évidemment alimenté par les
images par les informations par les
massacres perpétrés par les terroristes
du ramasse avec cette dernière
information qu'on va prendre avec
prudence elle est tombée en en fin
d'après-midi vous allez suivre
exactement notre notre réflexion
là-dessus il y a d'abord une dépêche de
l'agence France Presse qui nous dit que
les combattants palestiniens du ramas
ont lancé une offensive samedi dans le
sud d'Israël ont tué plus de 100
personnes dans un kibuts un seul kibuts
à Berry on est prêt d'une ville qui
s'appelle karaza et c'est le
porte-parole d'une ONG qui s'appelle
Zaka qui qui a participé à
l'identification des corps voilà ce
qu'il nous dit selon l'Agence France
Presse ils étaient très nombreux plus de
100 morts les hommes du Hamas sont tiré
sur tout le monde ils ont assassiné de
sang frroid des enfants des bébés des
gens âgés tout le monde voilà pour la
première source ensuite Laeticia il y a
une autre source qui est un média
israélien oui c'est un magazine en ligne
the times of israë qui publie un papier
qui dit qui raconte hein comment l'armée
israélienne a conduit des journalistes
de la presse étrangère dans ce kibuts
c'est un général de Tsahal qui a pris la
parole et donc qui s'est adressé aux
journalistes de la presse étrangère en
disant ce n'est pas une guerre ce n'est
pas un champ de bataille c'est un
massacre et et il a fait aussi référence
au pogrom que dit-il nos grands-mères et
nos grands-pères ont vécu en Europe donc
ils ont convié les journalistes voilà de
la presse étrangère pour montrer ce qu'
s'était passé dans dans ce kibuts Julien
Balou euh quelles informations
ressortent en ce moment là en cette fin
d'après-midi de mardi à propos de ce qui
je reste prudent voilà c'est ma nature
ce qui se serait passé dans ce kibuts de
Berry le kibut de Berry et le kibut de
tofar AAS desib que je connais bien euh
j'ai couvert la guerre de 2014
essentiellement là-bas c'est face à la
bande de gazas c'estd vous êtes dans le
jardin des gens et vous voyez la
barrière vous voyez la bande de gaz
advance
euh estce que c'est c'est un sujet qui
qui é extrêmement douloureux mais le
Zaka l'organisation que Don vous citez
c'est une organisation officielle c'est
pas une c'est pas quelque chose
d'officieux c'est eux qui s'occupent de
de de de rassembler les cadavres et les
mors pour que ce sont des gens très
religieux qui selon la la foi juive
veulent que les corps soient enterrés
entier donc leur travail après les
attentats c'est d'aller sur les lieux
d'attentat et de rassembler les morceaux
et identifier les morceau de tous les
cadavres et les mettre ensemble c'est
ils ont fait ce travail même que je peux
dire par exemple après le tsunami en
Thaïlande et sur de choses euh Zaka a
annoncé qu'il a eu 106 cadavres dans le
kibutberé euh Zaka ne balance pas de
fauses information donc il y a vraiment
eu s cadavre
akfaraza encore une fois que je connais
bien j'ai beaucoup de souvenirs très
douloureux euh il semble qu'il y a eu un
bain de sang on sait pas combien vous
parlez tout à l'heure de ce de ce de
cette conférence de presse qui é
organisée avec la presse étrangère avec
par un général je suis au courant
j'entends des chiffres circulé je ne
peux pas les confirmer c'est sûr qu'il y
a des dizaines de cadavres euh c'est
Zaka qui a identifier 260 corps sur le
lieu de du festival de musique dans le
sud il je juste un petit parle beaucoup
gopolitique je don un petit mot plus un
peut-être plus humain samedi matin LCE
que moi je me réveille à l'au par les
sirènes tel avive et que on descend aux
abris on comprend pas ce qui se passe
c'est samedi c'est Chapat il y a pas
d'information c'était une fête juive il
y a pas de raison qu'il y a une guerre à
ce moment-là
j'allum info il y a même pas une info
qui circule et je pense même à un bug
pour tout dire et on remonte chez nous
nous et y a rien il y a rien à la télé
et il commence à avir des vidéos de
terroristes qui rentrent dans les villes
deot qui rentrent à et cetera et je
crois que ce sont des fakees j'étais sûr
que c'est vidé qui de syri je croyais
même pas le traumatisme il est entier on
a j'ai eu des conversations WhatsApp de
gens que je connais également ou des
gens qui m'ont circul qui m qui m'ont
envoyé où disait maman papa te tué et de
nous ils sont derrière la porte ils sont
en train de tous me tuer souvenez-vous
le 13 novembre souvenez-vous le bataacan
souvenez-v imaginez 200 300 salar
Abdeslam qui débarqueent chez vous ou Mo
il y a un traumatisme il y a a la
société israélienne est en train
d'enterrer plus de 900 morts on est un
pays de 9 millions d'habitants je sais
pas si vous imaginez le drame et donc
juste pour bien comprendre désolé hein
Julien baloule mais je je vois que
évidemment c'est c'est douloureux pour
vous d'en parler mais ce sont deux sites
différents dont on parle oui oui il y a
il y a faraza et il y a Berry il a il y
a plein de petits Kibo Kibo c'est des
petits villages Berry c'est 1200
habitants 1200 1500 habitants donc
imaginez s'il y a là-bas 106 cadavres
alors ils sont peut-être pas tous des
habitants peut-être qu'il y a aussi des
soldats parmi les cadavres mais il y a
1200 1500 habitants en 2021 le
ressensement était de 1100 habitants à
Berry euh il y a plein de petits
villages comme ça il a nose Berry nativa
Sara et cetera et cetera et cetera c'est
des petits villages des des qui vivent
face à la frontière qui ont vécu les les
infiltrations terroristes en 2014 et là
qui ont vu des gens littéralement
débarquer dans le maison qui ont
incendié leur maison pour qu'il sortent
qui ont attrapé il y il y a des femmes
âgées de plus de 80 ans aotage il y a
une femme avec des bébés otage voilà h
un témoignage qui nous vient justement
de ce kibot de Berry c'est une une femme
qui a passé 15h enfermée dans un abri
elle raconte comment les les gens qui
étaient autour d'elle ont bloqué la
porte
écoutonsla lorsque nous nous sommes
caché dans l'AB nous n'avions aucune
idée de ce qui se passait à l'extérieur
nous entendions des voix en arabe nous
les entendions dire Dieu est le plus
grand abattez les juifs ils ont essayé
d'ouvrir la porte de l'abri il n'y a pas
de serrure elle ne ferme pas à clé il
suffit de soulever la poignée mon mari
et les trois garçons n'ont pas lâché la
poignée de la porte pendant 15 he
Patricia lémonère on on reste prudent
sur ce qui s'est passé dans ces de
kibuts même si j'entends les arguments
très forts de Julien baloule dans dans
dans ce type de conflit il y a
toujours des images ou un moment qui va
qui va cristalliser les les réactions
l'opinion et qui sera peut-être celui
dont on se souviendra est-ce que c'est
peut-être de ça dont on dont on est
témoin en ce moment alors il y a
effectivement une guerre des images hein
des deux côtés euh mais il y a je crois
côté côté israélien il y a une peur qui
est ancestrale pratiquement qui s'est
réveillé là et qui fait que
effectivement c'est la peur des pogromes
c'est la peur des des des de la Choa et
et c'est remonté et c'est dans cette
terre où il se croyaient en sécurité et
bien c'est vient d'être bafoué et et le
but de l'organisation le Hamas est
totalement atteint puisque il a créé la
terreur et et cette terreur est
entretenue par des images images qu'on a
vu au départ avec les ces fameux euh euh
amoto euh qui rentrait et qui massacrait
et aussi on va voir maintenant les
images parce que ça va être aussi
utilisé les images de la douleur des
Palestiniens parce que moi j'ai on a
tous été enfin certains ici ont été à
Gaza sous les bombes c'est ce qui s'y
passe est abominable aussi et donc on va
voir les images de ces de ces mères de
ces enfants perdus euh de de de ces
gosses ou des copains sont morts sous
leurs yeux et cetera de plus la soif la
fin je ce sont des images dont on a
malheureusement l'habitude hein oui mais
on va les voir et donc on va avoir une
un combat d'image et ce que j'espère
c'est qu'on a'ura pas le dernier le plus
abominable ce qui serait avec des otages
oui un un mot de ce combat d'image latia
qui qui a effectivement déjà commencé
rapidement je la parole je vous entends
hein mais je je je pense que ce combat
d'image cette guerre de communication
est dymétrique pour le moment pourquoi
parce que le Hamas a frappé vite et très
fort Thomas pourquoi parce qu'il a lancé
son offensive surprise et en même temps
vraiment dès les premières minutes il a
commencé le ramas à diffuser sur les
réseaux sociaux des images des vidéos
voilà qui étaient quasiment en simultané
pourquoi on sait que ça a été préparé
cette attaque parce que par exemple vous
avez raison Patricia on a vu des images
de combattant du Hamas dans ces
paramoteurs on a on avait l'impression
que c'était des parapantes mais ce sont
des paramoteurs parce qu'ils sont partis
du ciel on les a vu les combattants
monter dans ses par préparer oui
évidemment tout ça a été filmé donc il y
avait la la logique de communication la
guerre informationnelle qui qui se
prépara aussi voilà on a même vu les les
tuies oui et ensuite voilà très vite
dans la matinée samedi
matin dans la ville deot on a vu les les
civils les corps gisant dans dans les
rues très vite et vous avez raison patri
ensuite aussi samedi matin les otages
les vidéos des otages ont commencé à
circuler partout et pourquoi c'est
puissant Thomas parce que déjà les
médias du monde entier les ont reprises
mais aussi parce que n'importe qui a un
téléphone portable dans les mains a vu
ces images donc vous avez raison le but
de du Hamas c'était de sidérer et de
terroriser votre avis et puis ensuite
général Trincant vous vouliz prendre la
parole oui c'estàd que il y a plusieurs
choses la première c'est sur le 11
septembre cette comparaison avec le 11
septembre moi j'éta aux États-Unis juste
après euh et c'est vrai que la
comparaison elle tient elle tient dans
la souffrance elle tient dans la
sidération aussi dans la sidération et
dans la douleur des gens c'est c'est
c'est un traumatisme aux États-Unis et
aujourd'hui en Israël c'est un
traumatisme moi j'ai des amis israéliens
et je j'ai vu leur et des gens de gauche
qui sont totalement tout à l'heure
c'était bien sûr il y a ça une fois que
qu'on a qu' qu'on est dans cette émotion
qu'il faut prendre en compte ensuite la
la question elle est elle est politique
à un moment donné qu'est-ce qu'on fait
or et là il y a une différence radical
entre ce qui a pu se passer à New York
ou ce qui s'est passé à Paris et ce qui
s'est passé là-bas nous sommes dans dans
un contexte radicalement différent nous
sommes là en israël-pestine dans une
guerre qui dure depuis très longtemps et
donc la la la la la ripost de quelle
nature elle va être si alors on en revi
on débat tout à l'heure mais il faut
vraiment faire cette distinction elle
est fondamentale puis deuxième chose que
je voulais dire c'est que le Hamas est
intervenu par la violence et ça il
fallait s'y attendre c'est pas nouveau
et et je crois qu'il a ça a permis de
remettre au cœur la la réalité de la
centralité de la question palestinienne
que tout le monde voulait essayer
d'évacuer le problème que je crois
important oui il y a sans doute il y a
sans doute non je vais vous laisser
terminer mais il y a a il y a
certainement un objectif politique mais
il y a aussi la question enfin le ramas
ne se cache pas de vouloir faire
disparaître l'État d'Israël et et de
vouloir les Juifs ENF pe termin PHAs si
je peux terminer la phrase je pense que
il y a il y a cette idée de de remettre
la question palestinienne et ça je pense
que c'était d'une logique dans tout ce
qu'on a pu dire mais ce qui est
dramatique et à mon avis euh qui va
peser extrêmement lourd c'est que le
fait d'avoir commis ces crimes de guerre
h euh que vous que vous rappelez à juste
titre voir ces crime contre l'humanité
ça ça va complètement décrédibiliser et
et ça va complètement mettre en question
euh cette je pense que c'est un obl
stratégique et en même temps il se il se
dévalorise complètement c'est
inacceptable à tous égards donc on est
dans une espèce de contradiction et je
pense que malheureusement la réponse va
être sécuritaire et la réponse
sécuritaire ça va donner un amas de
cendre pas possible où le politique va
être complètement enseveli c'est ça qui
m'inqu domque trinant un mot rapide
ensuite on parle des otages Fran juste
un point sur la la communication elle va
évoluer dans le temps aujourd'hui on va
voir
la la communication très violente sur
les morts israéliens sur et cetera mais
si la guerre va dans Gaza bombarde dans
Gaza rentre dans Gaza sur la
durée d'autres images et là on va
trouver des crimes de guerre crimes avec
le risque que les otaches soient
utilisés en bouclier humain ça c'est
vraiment là on va avoir des crimes de
Gude il y a quand même justu une
remarque c'est la 4e Convention de
Genève une puissance occupante est tenue
d'assurer un minimum et et et cette 4è
cons va balayer et on avir des crimes de
Guer c'est la question du siège
notamment c'est aussi la question du
siège complet de Gaza qui est contraire
au droit humanitaireu rappelle le droit
sur son rôle ça fait longtemps que le
droit est n'est pas Israël ne suit pas
le droit ne serait-ce que que Israël
détient sans limite des gens sans
accusation ça c'est contre le droit donc
le droit
Israël israë et dans un autre combat et
dans une autre dimension ouais allez on
va parler des otages français grâce à
Quentin calm tout de suite merci de nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau
Quentin là aussi les les informations
évoluent en cette fin d'après-midi que
sait-on
des ressortissants français qui sont
portés disparu et bien on vient de
l'apprendre il y a quelques minutes il
serait 20 au total qui sont
effectivement porté disparu en ce mardi
soir et le bilan qui a évolué aussi sur
le nombre de Français tués depuis samedi
ce sera total 8 français le bilan depuis
hier soir s'établissait à quat français
tués et 13 disparus il est donc de 8
français tués 20 disparu cet après-midi
encore la première ministre lors des
questions d'acctité au Gouvernement
parlait de quatre Français tué 13
disparu écoutez Elisabeth borne c'était
il y a quelques heures h nous déplorons
à l'heure actuelle quatre décès parmi
nos ressortissants et nous cherchons
encore des nouvelles de 13 de nos
compatriotes dont la situation est
extrêmement
préoccupante certains sont probablement
pris en otage parmi eux un enfant de 12
ans nous sommes en lien constant avec
les familles et mes pensées vont vers
elles et nous veillons en lien avec Air
frrance à ce que des vols puissent
reprendre au plus vite voilà donc
c'était en fin d'après-midi on est à 8
morts et 20 disparus pour donner le le
dernier bilan qui est cet enfant de 12
ans dont parle la la première ministre
il s'agit effectivement d'un ado de 12
ans et demi etitan habitant du kibutz de
Near odods et enlevé samedi à moto par
le Hamas sa tante a posté un message sur
Facebook il a disparu avec son père il a
la nationalité française par sa mère
deux autres Français portés disparu ont
été identifiés dans la presse Thomas
Céline B 32 ans n'a plus donné signe de
vie depuis samedi alors qu'elle se
rendait au festival tribe of Nova le
festival dont on parle beaucoup qui a
fait aussi de nombreuses victim éé ciblé
par par le Hamas ouais absolument c'est
dans ce même festival qu'un deuxième
franco-israélien a été enlevé il
s'appelle avidane T et on voit l'extrême
prudence des autorités français qui en
disent le moins possible sur le décompte
on comprend merci beaucoup Quentin pour
ces informations Dominique trinc
évidemment la présence d'otage étranger
complique quand même la la ripos
militaire de de TS non très honnêt je ne
crois
pas sont des sont des binationaux pour
Israël ce sont des Israéliens comme les
autres et si la décision a été prise d'y
aller malgré tout et et de sacrifier
d'une certaine façon les otages parce
que moi la pression de on imaginer que
le gouvernement français ou d'autres
pays sont en train d'en parler
avecver g israélien latique doit arrêter
maintenant mais je je répète moi moi
c'est les échos que j'ai d'Israël c'est
pas ma conviction c'est que aujourd'hui
ils ont décidé d'attaquer Gaza et en
attaquant Gaza ils savent très bien
qu'ils vont sacrifier alors bien sûr on
va dire on fera tout notre possible pour
sauver les les otages mais derrière ça
il y a pas grand-chose sauver des otages
ça veut dire avoir du renseignement pour
savoir où ils sont et aller faire une
opération chirurgicale pour aller les
chercher je crois qu'il y a assez peu de
chance pour que ça se produise comme ça
alors je voudrais qu'on écoute parce que
là on est en train de se concentrer sur
la question des des otages effectivement
vous on l'a évoqué les uns et les autres
l'arme c'est sans doute le terme qu'il
faut ou le bouclier je sais pas le terme
qu'il faut employer que ça peut
représenter aux mains du Hamas je vous
propose d'entendre une réaction sur ce
thème c'est le porte-parole des brigades
ezedin al cassem qui dit précisément ce
qui va se passer à chaque fois que le
peuple sera pris pour cible ce sont ces
mots on
l'écoute nous annonçons qu'à partir de
maintenant chaque fois que notre peuple
sera pris pour cible sans avertissement
cela entraînera malheureusement
l'exécution d'un des otages civils de
l'ennemi nous serons contraint de le
diffuser en audio et en
vidéo jeanpa chagol oui je crois que je
crois que la question de desotages ne se
réduit pas simplement à tout ou rien je
pense pas que il est possible que
certains militaire parle comme vous
l'avez évoqué moi j'ai eu d'autres échos
l'affaire est complexe et en particulier
il y a déjà en ce moment des des des
négociations des médiations il y a déjà
des demandes qui ont été faites en
particulier pour échanger des otages
contre un certain nombre d'objectifs
notamment des prisonniers palestiniens
donc les si si la l'offensive terrestre
tarde un peu car aur pu déjà déclencher
sans doute j'en sais rien je suis pas
militaire mais il est clair que ça ne va
pas être du tout au rien ça va être plus
complexe que ça et par conséquent je
crois est-ce qu'il y a deux lignes au
sein du has voz ce que dire est-ce qu'il
y a des gens avec qui on peut discuter
dans anation comme celle-là mais il y a
toujours eu des négociations avec
leamass
toujours y a eu des négociations à
chaque fin de de de conflit il y a eu
des négociations sur les prisonniers
dans des conditions multiples donc c'est
clair que il y a un objet politique et
c'est ça qui est important c'est de
temps en temps quand nous parlons tout
ça ramenons un peu le politique et bien
entendu les Israéliens s'il peuvent
sauver des otages même en lâchant des
prisonniers palestinien ils le feront et
le Qatar ou l'Égypte jou un rôle
là-dessus ça va pas du tout au rien
c'est plus comp on va terminer là-dessus
il nous reste quelques minutes dans dans
ce premier débat qui peuvent être les
intermédiaires si si on si on cherche
autre chose que la réplique militaire et
la et le GLF de fer pour reprendre les
les termes de l'armée Israël alors on
peut dire que que le Qatar a un
savoir-faire en matière d'otage de
paiement de rançon et cetera il s'est
illustré de dans le globe et c'est et
actuellement on disait mais ça été on a
dit que non les autorités ont dit que
non mais en fait le Qatar il y a une
proposition de libérer les femmes et les
enfants contre des Palestiniennes détenu
37 palestiniennes détenu dans dans les
prisons israéliennes les chiffres me
semblent complètement farfelu parce
qu'en général c'est pas pour 37
Palestiniens qu' qu'on va libérer des
femmes et des enfants
Israëliens ça il y a cette possibilité
là sur un plan plus politique et plus
militaire en quelque sorte j'ai envie de
dire que l'Égypte a toujours joué un
rôle c'est elle qui est le le le le
makeur en quelque sorte si on peut dire
ça des accord politique pratiquement des
des cess le feu tous les cess le feu
passent par l'Égypte et il y a d'autres
aujourd'hui d'autres intervenants il y a
la Turquie qui peut jouer aussi un rôle
parce que n'oublions pas le Hamas à son
origine est un mouvement frère musulman
même si avec l'Iran maintenant il a
évolué et ce mais il reste profondément
attaché à la tradition
FR et la Russie qui sont les deux pays
qui disent État palestinien qui
remettent cette question
sur
tradition du politique il faut
absolument sortir j'entends bien sûr
qu'il faudrait en sortir SAU que
ême dire
dansitaireitaireè est çaut le politique
qui choisit l'option
militaire est-ce que les deux les deux
leviers peuvent cohabiter vous voyez ce
que je veux dire l'action militaire on
imagine une ripost de de dans la bande
de Gaza ça va sans doute arriver et à
côté de ça des négociations qui on
peut-être déjà commencé et qui continu
mais bien sûr négoci des discussions
évidemment mais même dans l'action
militaire il y a des forces spéciales
dont le boulot va être de chercher les
aotage pour essayer de les sortir
vivants pendant l'opération de
destruction du Hamas donc tout ceci va
va arriver maintenant sur quoi est-ce
que ça débouchera là je suis beaucoup
plus incertain un dernier mot dans ce pr
opération militaire pour Israël est
essentielle parce qu'il faut restaurer
son
invulnérabilité et donc elle ne peut pas
se passer de cette opération
malheureusement je crois que ça peut pas
être à n'importe quel prix merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vais
rappeler les titres de vos livres je
commence avec vous Dominique trincon ce
qui nous attend l'effet papillon des
conflits mondiaux publiés aux éditions
Robert Lafond Patricia lémonè au cœur du
chaos c'est aux éditions harto et puis
Jean-Paul chagnolo Israël-Palestine la
défaite du vainqueur voilà on est au
cœur de notre débat chez Acte Sud